good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday June third
twenty nineteen answer my call
to order please be advised of
the audio and video recorded
please proceed is being made
this telephone a man surgery
please call the roll Cooley here
Cunningham Carillo yeah flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove here
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos Rivas Wicks
we have a quorum we have a
consider gender is our motion
concerned Chen members Chris
second ever miss wicks -- mass
action please call the roll
Cooley hi Lee I Cunningham
Carillo hi Carillo aye flora
floor I Grayson Grayson aye
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove
five Maienschein Maienschein
aye Mathis Mathis I Burke
cellphone promos Ramos I Rivas
Wicks Wicks I'd commission
have since most as fast
and this was prison terms
thank you very much calling